peu
et vous par exemple de votre bande
mariage est
si ce temps ben bernanke entier à agir
c'est partout pareil contient un chef
l'époque se sépare pas rester avec lui
on l'accomplît canne à pêche et autres
il était une fois square un square comme
beaucoup d'autres
il était une fois aussi une bonne deux
garçons des 12 à 14 ans deux garçons qui
ne rentrent pas chez eux après l'école
mais qui traîne indéfiniment jusqu'à la
tombée de la nuit pour tout le monde ce
sont des petits voyous mais qui les
connaît thierry et ses copains et said à
l'école de passer leur certificat
d'études
c'est pourtant dans la rue ou au square
qu'ils apprennent la vie
elle a une voix sylvain ne suis pas tu
nous vois moi je veux ta main seulement
on voit sa main en aura un en avant à ta
tête à sylvain vous voilez norway as
much as pas moi moi moi c'est tout
bailleur de fonds à ces conneries merde
il faut que gentiment - huawei soit
enfin me faire la manche bellon est allé
au fond comment vas tu es là on change
pas je mange à bigs et demi environ
nous a pas
en six matchs sur arte avec tout ce que
je fais est poussive
bon bah tu vas pas mourir moi aussi j'en
prends des coups web entend taper pop et
bien pourquoi t'es pas rentrer et
acadiens orange
j'ai géré alors un danger car j'ai
d'ailleurs à kuyt à manger chez moi
maintenant un défaut entre les epub
quoique at elle tout en restant ferme
au jeu
nous embauchons
je pressens
mais chez toi y'a personne
en voyant personne ne pensait à part la
personne
ce travail a montré un autre contrat de
travail fait des remplacements
pour thierry et ses copains l'évasion la
plus proche et la plus attirante
c'est pigalle
revenge
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on fasse
aujourd'hui son analyse par mois à
beloeil et la piscine non je ne vais pas
vous dire une chose qu'on aura embauché
à berne
comme ça on pourra y aller aujourd'hui
des troupes dans la bagnole quand on est
et on prend elle avait expliqué des
trucs
quant à lui dit d'aller à notre dame ont
emballé d'être que sa vie était des
trucs
c'est quoi ça c'est pas les invalides
c'est peut-être quand elle viola c'est
pas un louvre par user sa femme musée
grévin a way to surgery ça bouge à
visiter moi là dedans c'est la voile a
été mis en taule jeanne d'arc dans les
sous-sols tchad à un par un au cou en
sang à paris jeudi au caire
et il veut le programme en ce moment
dont je tiens du ton si red road
tu vois c'est ça les invalides au
pas que ces grands à temps mais après je
crois que tu vas voir la forte alors
qu'il ya plein de cadeaux alors de plus
que ses gardes et un ariary tension de
la garza dernière guerre regarde le
peuple tu le vois ouais il doit y en
avoir en obtiendrait en garde les canons
elle a bien rappelé on regarde les cas
l'on là à temps là aussi la non il doit
dater je crois qu'il est dans le tchat
entre confiance en france un ancien du
sétois à la gare quand ils se sont
servis
par tranche c'est un quartier super
cauchy à l'asm
parce qu'ici tu vois pas de mon petit
peu rien des clips leur table à 500
balles et tu vas t'amuser n'importe quoi
qu'il dise on est sur la chemin en
europe
les barons tu vois jamais lu merkel un
toit ça se voit quand quelqu'un du souci
ça
tout cela
ah oui
mais aussi super elle regarde je te
marquer des noms
en tout les nouveaux horizons hâtez-vous
je marquais le mien
pour la bande le point de ralliement
c'est toujours le square
ici tous les habitués les connaissent de
vue tout temps mais qui leur parle qui
s'intéresse à eux
enfin on s'est passé les jours sont pour
sa part ont leurs papiers
ils sont sympas les gens non principe
lugeur pour les journaux
ce qui me prend comprendre c'est que
aussi dans le pigeon creusot mais on
préférait avoir des amis ou des amis
vu les n8 et historique mois pourquoi
parce
les amis on les connaît
rendez vous à tous les ennemis en
principe
un fond d'écran
des amis question des traces
celles qui sont visées
dieppois
vous faites des crasses entre vous et
les faux nom
il s'est écrasé
petite vacherie on croit que ça peu
d'importance que ça
un groupe
c'est qui c'est
gallen
[Applaudissements]
on prend un point c'est une trace comme
ça mais c'est dégueulasse t as pas leur
temps on retrouve comme si dégueulasse
tu pars tu lui dis alors on me demande
quelque chose donc eu dans la panse pour
moi tu pourrais pas dire quand tu parles
et dans la vie tu crois que les gens
cèdent où ils vivent pour eux-mêmes seul
il y en a qui y en a qui cède parisien
qui fait il y en a qui conseilleront on
peut on en aura pour beaucoup qui sait
dans quoi tu aimerais 1 un monde où tout
le monde s'est leurré centre et devrait
annoncer ce lundi nous alors
qu'est ce que ça serait pour toi alors
ici
imaginez quand c'est ce que serait pour
toi demande où ce serait bien ce serait
trop conti
comment ça peut pas exister faut pas
imaginer comme ça
si on imagine bien con
comprendre la réalité
message plus dur je pense
tu crois que je suis sympa
oui
en option pour tenter d'étayer le
carreau tomber
quand
dix ans
alors ce qui m'a donné
oh
bildt
vous étiez carancho
je dirais même pas déçu
m
non sans mal au québec aux placements
bien enrichi
et en effet souvent bien non
pour quelles raisons
monsieur
ce jeu vol
les mêmes qualités si vous qu'on fait ça
je peux le revoir
à part ces sites à suivant alors mes
copains quoi faire confiance et
justement quand tu voudrais avoir un
travail pour te ferais confiance - ch
et tu crois que tu transporter de
l'argent plus non pas du tout tenté de
prendre tout le monde
justement ça prouvera que chez moi tenir
le seul adulte que la bande fréquente
est un éducateur cgil
[Applaudissements]
il vient les voir une ou deux fois par
semaine alors ils ont trouvé du travail
illégal le garage qu'est ce que c'est
ainsi qu'est ce que vous faites
balayons pan du travail paye c'est
durant cette veillée ne mettra plus
value de salaire est ce que vous avez
fait comme conneries quand vous avez dû
en faire quelques jours en lui est si
les images tu as une image pour 20
litres on achète un paquet d'image comme
ça pas trop hilario et puis facile 20,6
et six boeufs
well done moi ça toi fais ça au patron
c'est le mec d'en face qui me l'a donnée
les afriques met à l'essai
et c'est resté combien de temps dans le
garage o comme ça à leur meilleur ennemi
on termine à rio on va rester jusqu'à
toi mais combien de jours va jusqu'à
temps dans strasbourg
ce qui attend que vous fassiez viré
parce que je pense que morose un gars
comme ça qu'on devait quitter mardi
qu'est ce que tu fais avec ce que je
fais c'est avant tout une présence avec
eux j'essaye d'être là le maximum et
puis à partir de là d'essayer de voir
quelles sont leurs inspirations
ok qu'est ce qu'ils veulent faire
pourquoi et pourquoi ils veulent pas
faire ceci vous pouvez pas faire cela
mais en dehors des parents et de vous de
l'instituteur et connaissent pas
d'autres ordures
presque dix ans
serre qu'ils arrivent pas ils en
connaissent beaucoup n'arrivent pas à
entrer vraiment en contact avec eux
oui
à établir une relation qui se voit pas
ceux de dépendance enfin où vous pris
pour des petits que toujours la fin ils
en ont marre sans jamais me mis en
valeur dans leur action c'est assez rare
que ce soit à l'école sur l'otan chez
eux davantage
chez eux il ya quand même toujours au
moins la fin la mer qui essayent de
de comprendre l impression qu on les
rejette le sont pratiquement partout
doivent surtout à la lâchent qu'ils ont
pour ça
le temps
stage là on les rejette systématiquement
pratiquement
parce que ils font jamais ce que ce
qu'on attendait
le résultat le certificat wesh alors je
les prends le cas dans le rouge je vais
jamais à l'école parce que va faire
alors 5 centilitres m
j'allais à l'école
tu es retour bah ouais choi jai
pendant tu sais pas où je dirais pas
ah non que tu ferais
je vois dans la honte
mais sais tu veux apprendre les métiers
d'art ou par non et ça va durer
comme ça longtemps qu'il veut faire un
métier tu m'as dit ouah mais façon
certes au si tu n'as pas tu arriveras
pas faire ce que tu veux
non
c'est pour que je veux c'est pas que je
suis peu mon jeu je pense pas
sincèrement bien mais alors comment
faire tu veux tu sais ce que tu veux
faire comme métier c'est qu'il faut
certificat que je dis ça puis ça se
trouve je n'aurai pas la patience de le
faire en métier
g bâle renan à la moto je me passerais
clés sur sept mois il ya des trucs qui
m'énervent c'est pour ça que je me
convient pas et maintenant c'est la fin
de l'émission
ce que vous dites mais d'un ça passera à
la fin d'émission
et l état de gens qui vous connaît trop
bien
mieux certainement que vous même vous
connaissez et vous car vous allez sortir
le lendemain la diffusion de l'émission
vous allez sortir dans la rue au square
à l'école il ya des précisé sa femme il
ya des gens qui vont vous connaître ils
vont savoir ce que vous êtes venus alors
que vous leur parier qu est ce que vous
allez leur dire quelles impressions vous
allez avoir des vues basse et bien voilà
qu'on en dise ah voilà avant nous
traiter de petit voleur petit voyou ah
ouais
[Musique]